- So just as a tiny bit of introduction,
mentorship can be defined
in a lot of different ways,
but the way I think about it anyway,
is that it encompasses a lot of things.
Mentors can be your advisors or PIs
who are formally responsible
for your academic progress,
it can be supporters of your personal
and professional endeavors,
teachers, even trainers,
maybe you have sponsors and allies,
maybe you have academic role models
as future faculty and
leaders beyond the academy,
really anyone who you
can find who can help you
reach your professional goals.
So on the flip side, we
expect you, our students,
to weave together the network you need
of resources and advisors,
so that you can pursue
your intellectual and professional goals.
And your needs from mentors
will vary of course,
across your disciplines
and the type of degree
you're working on, as well as
where you are in your program.
What you need as a beginning student
will change over time
as you make progress.
However, and there are some things,
some shared values and
goals and responsibilities
that really underpin all effective
mentorship relationships,
and those include the
need to be self-directed,
to be really intrinsically motivated,
and to be able to persevere
through rough spots,
'cause we all have those.
And if you can do that and reach out,
you can definitely find
supportive scholars
and friends to make
your graduate education
wonderful in a collaborative way.
You are definitely not alone,
Yale is teaming with advisors and mentors,
and that includes faculty of course,
but also deans, and staff,
advanced students, peers,
really, this is a people
to people endeavor
we're doing and you should tap into
all the help you can get.
So today we're focusing on a particular
type of mentorship and
that's exemplified in
the grad school by our annual
graduate mentor awards,
and these celebrate faculty members
who have been outstanding
teachers and advisors
of graduate students, and
the three faculty members
who are here today on the
panel are all past winners
of the graduate mentor award,
which means they were
nominated by their current,
or past, or both, mentees for this award,
for their exemplary behaviors.
So they really exemplify
the important qualities
to which all graduate teachers
and faculty mentors should aspire.
So just brief introductions.
Gary Brudvig is the Silliman
Professor of Chemistry,
and Professor Brudvig's students
have remarked that somehow he manages
to, sorry, I lost my place,
I'm moving my screen around,
somehow he manages to be inspiring
and scientifically
challenging at the same time
without being intimidating or demanding.
He allows his mentees to use
their time in graduate school
to develop as scientists and people
in the ways we find most valuable.
One student wrote, quote, this is a quote,
"Of course, the chemistry
is always the main goal,
but Gary also encourages
students to spend time
taking extra classes,
gaining teaching skills,
and leading outreach efforts.
I think the best way to
sum up what makes Gary
such a great advisor and
mentor is that he allows
for each of his students
to have the flexibility
to follow their own passions."
So Gary thanks for being here.
- Yeah, my pleasure.
- Next, Kelly Shue is Professor of Finance
at the School of Management.
Professor Shue is known
to go above and beyond
to support her PhD advisees.
Students note that she cares deeply
about their personal
and professional success
and does everything she can to help them
reach their full potential as scholars.
One student remarked, "In a year when
many academic conferences
have been canceled
or gone virtual, Professor
Shue tried to make up
for the lost networking opportunities
by connecting students
with other faculty members
who do work in the same fields,
she will go the extra
mile for her advisees."
Thanks for being here and
thanks for all of that.
And our third faculty
member here with us today
is Joanne Meyerowitz, who is the Arthur
Unobskey Professor of History
and Professor of American Studies.
Professor Meyerowitz' students esteem her
as a dream advisor who teaches students
to read history while
sharpening their abilities
to identify trends in
historical scholarship.
One nominator wrote that she is
"Timely and thoughtful in her engagement
with student work, frank about the rewards
and difficulties of the
academic job market,
and consistently helpful
in directing her students
toward resources and
opportunities to develop
their scholarship and
intellectual community."
So thank you, all three of
you, as exceptional mentors
for providing insights today to students
and anyone else who's tuned in.
We are lucky to have you
here, thank you for doing it.
So now what I'd like to
do is hand the floor over
to Assistant Dean for
Graduate Student Life,
Matthew Tanico, who will
moderate the discussion.
So please enjoy everyone.
- Thank you, Lynn.
I just wanna reiterate
Dean Cooley's gratitude
for our panelist
participation this afternoon.
So we'll start with a few questions
that we've prepared in
advance for our panelists
and we'll reserve the
latter part of the panel
for Q and A from the audience,
so feel free to put questions in the chat,
I'll do my best to include questions
as they come up in the discussion,
but you can also save
questions till the end
and use the raise hand
feature to ask those live.
So I wanted to say that the word mentor
takes its etymological origin
from the character Mentor in the Odyssey.
And Mentor was the teacher and advisor
to Odysseus's son Telemachus
after Odysseus left for the Trojan War.
So that's to say that mentorship
is an ancient practice,
but to be effective, it also must account
for contemporary issues.
And so I hope that today's
discussion will address
the current needs of
both mentors and mentees
within higher education to build
the kinds of effective
mentorship relationships
that Lynn was describing earlier.
So I wanna start off the
conversation by asking
each of our faculty
panelists to talk about
their personal mentoring philosophies
and how they've adapted their practices
to the current realities
of graduate education,
which is both the
realities of the pandemic,
but also the changing nature
of what graduate education is for.
So I open the floor up to whomever
wants to begin with the discussion.
- Well, okay, I'll just jump right in.
So I would say that basically,
I see my role as an
advocate and a supporter
of the students who I advise
and who are in my classes,
but as an advocate who's willing to push,
who's willing to suggest ways to navigate
the institution and
especially to suggest ways
to improve scholarship, I believe in
sort of giving honest, and kind,
constructive feedback, but again,
let me emphasize the honest part,
I think it's really important to be honest
at the same time as kind and constructive.
And I'd say that my aim
is to work with students
to accomplish what they wanna accomplish,
to help them accomplish
what they wanna accomplish,
and that means listening
to what they want,
which isn't necessarily what I think
should be the topic of their
scholarship or whatever,
that's really up to the
students I work with,
and my goal is to help
them reach their goals.
And sometimes occasionally
that means intervening,
being a mediator on their behalf,
say intervening with
other faculty members,
or back when I was at DGS,
intervening with deans,
but only if a student requests
that kind of mediation,
that seems really
important to me to respect
a certain kind of, within the law,
certain kind of confidentiality.
And you asked about change over time too,
about sort of the recent changes,
and I would say that more recently
I've been giving more attention
to nonacademic careers,
as we all have, and the
possibilities for that
and listening to what it is that students
want to do with their
lives, and that could mean
following a non-academic trajectory
after getting a PhD, it
could mean dropping out
before getting a PhD,
I have students who've
chosen to forgo the dissertation and go be
a labor organizer or go
be a high school teacher,
and sometimes they think
that they're disappointing me
in doing that, and I wanna reassure them
that it's not a disappointment,
I want them to flourish, I want them to do
what they wanna do, and
I wanna support them
in whatever that is, and
whatever they've learned at Yale,
that will shape, it will
inform their lives after Yale,
whatever the career is.
And finally, I would say
that I pay more attention
now to mental health issues.
I think that we're all becoming more aware
of just how far graduate school can be.
- I'm happy to follow up.
So I try to actually follow
and get a read on what
the student would like
in terms of a mentoring relationship.
And I think graduate students
are highly idiosyncratic,
some people want a really
high touch relationship
in which I check in on them regularly,
they touch in with me regularly,
I think that can be a very effective,
other people can do very well with more
kind of formal meetings
or check in via email,
and if that's their
preferred mode of contact,
I think that can still work.
I think the benefit of
a university environment
is we can handle all
kinds of personalities
and preferences for
mentoring relationships
and also research styles.
So I'm a Professor in the
Finance group at Yale SOM,
and within the research
disciplines of finance,
economics, et cetera, we
don't really run labs,
it's really, there's students
who are doing their
independent research projects,
they might sometimes
coauthor with faculty,
but they're not tied to any particular
faculty member through a
laboratory relationship.
I think because of that, I try very hard
not to be territorial over students,
in fact, I really encourage them to find
multiple mentors, partly
so that they can get
multiple points of view,
but it also kind of
diversifies their risk
in terms of what if one
faculty member moves or gives advice
that ends up not being useful,
or let's say student
wants to work on something
interdisciplinary, so
they really need to make
a committee of people with
multiple areas of expertise.
Matthew had also asked about adapting to
modern demands, especially
with the pandemic.
What I've tried to do is I offer students
to meet over Zoom or in my office,
some people actually
prefer the convenience
of meeting over Zoom, doesn't require
that they're on campus,
especially if they have
family responsibilities or
they're stuck in another country.
And I've tried to be more of a listener
in terms of their other
problems in their lives,
it's important, I think that
I don't probe too much or ask,
but a lot of these problems do
just come up in conversation,
I think it's very useful
actually for me to know
just the context of
these research problems,
but then that's in a
context of a whole set of
issues that my students are dealing with.
- Yeah, I guess I can follow suit.
So I'm in the Chemistry Department
and we work in a lab as a team,
so I'll talk more in
terms of the mentoring
in that kind of an environment.
Graduate school is a
transition point where
you go from being an undergraduate
where you take courses,
and you learn, and
reiterate things that are
in the courses, to independent research
where you're blazing your own trail,
and you're doing independent work,
and you're not following
directions anymore,
and so my goal is to facilitate that,
and as Joanne said, to achieve your goals
in the end, and those goals might be
to become an academic or it may be
to work in industry, maybe
to become a consultant
or lots of different
directions, go to law school,
those are all directions students
from my group have taken.
And yeah, so within a team environment,
so one of the things I
really work to do is to
encourage team efforts and
people working together,
and that creates a level of interaction
and engagement that I think leads to
less isolation in a team effort.
You're not on your own, you're
really working as a team,
but on the other hand, everyone has to
follow their own path
and become independent
and learn how to do that.
And that's my goal, and
encouraging independent ideas.
I'm pretty much a hands off advisor,
and so I'm not looking every day, okay,
do this next, do that next, but really
we talk as a group every
week, many times a week,
actually, and it's to brainstorm together,
and work towards a
successful path forward.
And so that's my idea of mentorship,
and I think the pandemic has certainly
made it more difficult
for in person engagement,
but on the other hand,
it's also by using Zoom
as an opportunity to have
frequent face to face connections.
One of my challenges is my
research group is split,
part of my group is in
the Chemistry Department
on main campus, and the rest of my group
is on the west campus on the
Energy Science Institute.
And so it's not always
so easy to see each other
face to face all the time,
because back and forth travel,
but Zoom actually makes that a lot easier,
so there are some benefits to
that transition to
Zoom, we'll probably not
stop doing that, even when
things get more back to normal.
- Thank you all, that's great.
I think there's a clear sense of having
a student centered approach
and giving the students
independence while either connecting them
with resources or enabling them to pursue
those resources on their own,
that really comes through
in all of your answers.
There is currently a
trend in student affairs
to talk about the whole person approach,
and that it's impossible
to completely separate out
our personal and professional lives,
and yet boundaries are
necessary to maintain
healthy interpersonal
interactions across the board.
So could you talk a bit
about how you maintain
healthy relationships with your mentees
and what advice you would give students
for setting and respecting
boundaries with their mentors?
- I guess, I don't know if we wanna follow
the same sequence every
time, but I'll go this way,
we'll break the trend and we
can mix it up a little bit,
but I was gonna mention this before,
but please ask questions,
I'm more than happy to be interrupted,
and if you have any
questions you wanna follow up
or just ask something, please do so,
I think Matt's looking at the chat
if you wanna add something to the chat.
So as I mentioned, in a science group,
we work as a team, and most of the time
that is quite professional,
we're working on research,
talking about new results,
new plans for experiments,
and so on, but it also
creates kind of a family,
and we do things together, and so
it's not a complete division between
the science that we do and other things
outside of the lab as well,
so I think that's something that
is a good aspect of a
team that works in a lab,
and for example, my own research group,
they organized game nights during,
when we were shut down with COVID,
and so we did that on Zoom,
and that was fun, and not just
actually about a month ago,
we had a group ski trip,
and so we do some of those kind of things
just to foster a team effort,
but then I think everybody
has their own personal life
and that's separate, so
separate from the group,
and that's an important boundary
that I think I respect.
- Yeah, I would agree
that there are definitely
boundaries to respect,
I think that when I was,
I mean, I work more
one on one with people,
not in a lab setting,
so it's not that sort of
same group team building
spirit, except in the classroom.
And I think that when I was younger,
I felt, when I was much younger,
I felt more like a friend or a peer
with some of my students,
with my graduate students,
some of whom were
actually older than I was
way back then, but now I'm older
and I feel friendly,
but not like a friend,
and so I feel it's more of
a professional relationship.
I don't expect to be part of
my student's personal lives,
unless I'm explicitly invited to be,
invited to meet a partner or parents,
or go to a wedding or something like that,
but mostly professional, and I would say
I like to make myself available
to meet with advisees and students,
and I'm always happy to go out for coffee
or have lunch, but usually
that's in a campus setting,
not always, but almost
always in a campus setting,
again, that sort of
professional feeling to it.
And I know that there can be a kind of
fine line between
mentoring and surveillance,
and I want to be careful
not to cross that line,
I don't want anybody to feel
like I'm monitoring them
or invading their lives, and so really
it's more of expecting
students to come to me
when they need something from me
or want something from
me, and to make clear that
I'm a presence there for
them when they need me,
but not a constant
presence in their lives.
- Yeah, for me, personally,
this has so far not been much of an issue,
although I do have mixed views
on this question in general.
So personally I maintain a fairly
professional relationship with my mentees.
What I've noticed is
that after they graduate
we'll continue talking,
but then we move toward
a less of a professional
relationship and we can talk more
as colleagues and friends,
but that typically
happens after graduation
when my students get their first jobs.
I do have mixed views on this,
because I know there's
research showing that,
I think the research is about the unequal
access to schmoozing
and how much schmoozing
matters for career advancement.
But I do worry that the knee jerk reaction
to this research is
then we're just going to
ban all channels for schmoozing,
so faculty are perhaps
not going to be allowed
to invite students to
their homes for parties,
or we can't have meals with students,
because, well, if we can't offer the same
opportunity to all students,
then we just shouldn't do it at all.
And I'm not sure that's
the right way to go.
Instead, it really has to be about
students have to match
with the set of faculty
that they choose and they
have a good match with,
and part of that is through perhaps
more informal activities and talking about
more than just research.
So I'm not sure where
the right balance is,
but I would hope that we don't completely
ban or rule out these
opportunities as a school.
- So I think that's super helpful.
Building on that sort of how you approach
these relationships and build
out these relationships,
I think knowing what you want
and asking for what you need,
and knowing the difference
between those two things
is an essential piece of it,
and so negotiation, clear communication,
these are the things that
are crucial to making
that relationship successful.
So what advice would you
give to students for actually
communicating with their
mentors effectively,
and whether that's in
meetings, or via email,
or how often they should be
speaking with their mentors?
And I'm thinking also here more broadly
than just the faculty advisor
to student relationship,
I think we're getting at something here,
which is that you're
building a sort of culture
around yourself in some
of these relationships
and figuring out who to ask for when.
And so do you all have any advice around
sort of how to do that effectively
with the communication?
- One thing that I tell
all my students to do is,
maybe this applies more for students
for which on their dissertations
is really their job
to come up with a completely
independent topic,
as is the case in finance and economics,
what I tell them is, when they ask faculty
for feedback on research ideas,
is to ask them really to rank three ideas,
or rank more than one idea, and the idea
behind this advice is we would
like to give honest feedback,
but we also want to be
nice and supportive people.
So oftentimes if a student just
comes to our office with one
idea, we're gonna try to get
as much out of that idea as possible,
even if that idea may face various hurdles
to publication or job market success.
So coming to our office
hours or coming to talk to us
with three possible avenues of research
or specialization just allows us to
give more honest and helpful feedback.
- So I guess if my main piece of advice
would be to stay in
touch, to don't disappear.
So I think that mentors
and faculty advisors
and professors don't want to feel like
we have to chase after you
to find out how you're doing,
so that may sometimes be
that I'll take the initiative
and get in touch with
people, but generally
I expect students I work with to
let me know how they're
doing, and I don't mean
on a weekly basis or
daily basis, I just mean
make sure they staying in touch
and letting me know what's going on,
not in their personal lives,
but in their professional lives
and if need be in their
personal lives as well,
if they choose, so I think
that, that staying in touch is
not just about coming to
someone when you have a problem,
although that's a really
important thing to do,
but I think also to share your triumphs
with your professors, to
what are you accomplishing?
Where are you?
Your mentors wanna hear about
your hard spots you're having,
but your mentors will take great pride
in your accomplishments,
I mean, I can't tell you,
I feel real joy when one of my students
has some great accomplishment
and I want them
to let me know, so I
guess it's a matter of
maintaining a conversation across time,
and not, again, daily,
not necessarily weekly,
but just staying in touch, I
think that's really important
when there's a problem,
and even when there's not.
- Yeah, I guess it's a little
bit different in the sciences,
it's not that we're not
staying in touch, I mean,
I meet with everybody
in my group every week,
multiple times, but I'm not a mind reader,
so I don't know what
your problems might be
and things that you'd like advice on,
you have to ask, and so I think
setting up meetings and discussing
any topic you want, I mean, it could be
ranging from a different
research direction
versus a career pathway, or any aspect
in your career development.
I can tell you things, but
it may not be what you're
really concerned about or need advice on,
so I think asking, and in my own case,
I have, well before COVID,
an open door policy now,
I guess an open contact policy,
whether it's a Zoom meeting
or an email or what,
and I think encouraged
that, as Joanne said,
you've got stay in touch, tell us
what you're thinking and what you need,
you'd like us to give advice on.
- I can't help but think about my own time
in graduate school, and particularly
with what Joanne was
saying, where sometimes
you have a problem and you
don't wanna bring it up,
and the longer you keep
it from the conversation,
the worse it gets, and you just kind of
build this anxiety around it, and I think
that's important what all
of you were saying here
about just keeping the
constant conversation going.
We're getting a couple
of questions in the chat,
so I'm gonna switch gears a little bit
and sort of encourage
those, because we're here
to help students think through
the questions that they have.
So the first question
that we received was,
I'd love to hear our
guests reflection on advice
for students who have
co-advisors for a dissertation
in situations where they
have been a co-advisor,
what has worked best for
you in this situation?
Any tips for students in this situation,
we have been sort of thinking about
developing a relationship,
but sometimes there are
multiple people in that relationship,
so which adds complication, of course.
- I can lead into that,
because the research
we do is very collaborative, and in fact,
we've had a collaborative
project with several other
faculty members in the
Chemistry Department,
and so we've had many
formally co-advised students,
and most of them are informally,
but we meet as a team every week, and so
I think it's important to be consistent
on what you're saying when, of course,
we may raise questions about
interpretations and
maybe that's a little bit
different from one advisor to the other,
but we have to be consistent
in our support and advice on that,
otherwise there could be trouble,
and you need to work together on that,
but I think it could be,
I think one thing that facilitates that
is that we meet as a team, and have
round table discussion every week,
so we can sort of make sure everybody's
working in the same direction.
- So I do a lot of co-advising,
I think probably, I haven't counted,
but maybe more than half
of the dissertations
I've advised here have been co-advised,
and I think it's really not problematic,
I think it's a great thing.
But we're not working in a team in a lab,
and so usually an advisee
has independent relationships
with each of the co-advisors and gets
independent feedback from
them, and occasional,
sometimes that's nicely reinforcing,
we're all saying the same thing,
you need to reorganize in this way
and we both say the same
thing, and that's great,
and sometimes we say different things
and that makes for
interesting conversation.
And I don't think anybody expects you
to sort of favor one or the other,
but to follow your own guidance,
and if there's conflicting
advice to talk it out
and then do what you wanna
do and what you need to do.
So I don't think that it's ever
really been a problematic thing,
and I think it's nice for somebody to have
more than one person who they feel like is
their main advisor, so that
there's not just one person
who is responsible for giving
quick feedback and advice.
- Basically every
student that I've advised
has always been co-advising,
that's just kind of the structure of
dissertation committees
within finance and economics.
One problem here is that
oftentimes the advisors
do ask the students to go
in different directions,
and then the student is
unclear about how to proceed.
I think there it would really be helpful
if the student explained to each advisor
what the other advisors are suggesting,
because one problem
that I've seen emerge is
we, and I've heard this
from other faculty members,
will meet with a student,
recommend some direction,
a month later the student
hasn't done anything
regarding our suggestion,
and that actually
could be because the other faculty members
are suggesting something else, but it'd be
really helpful if we understood that
rather than thinking, oh,
it's because you've chosen
to do nothing over the course of a month.
Another strategy that has
worked is when the student
arranges for an internal presentation,
all the dissertation members are present,
and this could be done before kind of
formally scheduled presentation dates,
and that way all the committee
members are in one room,
and can kind of hash out the differences
in their suggested directions.
- Thank you, there are plenty
of questions coming in now,
so I'm just gonna keep
running through them.
Could you all speak to
the unique challenges
and perhaps opportunities and benefits
of being a mentor as a
tenure track professor,
as opposed to a tenured
professor with more job security?
I'm particularly curious
about time management
and I'd appreciate any
thoughts you have about this.
And this is really important
as students are becoming
mentors themselves as
well and becoming faculty.
- Yeah, I can maybe jump in on that.
I think there's a lot of pressure for
junior faculty members to be productive
and make a name for
themselves and make tenure.
And sometimes they put undue
pressure on their students,
and I think that's something
that you have to be
careful about, and I think that sometimes
can be leading to very
difficult arrangements.
And I know in my case it
probably was no exception,
but I really did try to look into
the direction of the students rather than
my own individual interests,
but there are realities and demands too,
and getting the results for
the next grant proposal,
and we all work as a
team to to try to work
on that and sometimes
that could be stressful,
but I think, again, working
together as opposed to
making demands is a good strategy.
- Within my area of finance
and economics research
I would say there's, I
mean, it's unfortunate,
but there's just no
incentive for junior faculty
to be effective mentors, or
to devote a lot of time to it.
Many of them are, but
I think that's because
they're intrinsically motivated
and they just like research
and talking about that
with students, but there's
almost nothing in it
for them in terms of
higher tenure probability,
because we don't work in labs,
mentoring students has no direct benefit
to our own research, it's really about,
many people do just like
to engage with students,
and I think as students
you should try to seek out
those people, but the way
the institution is designed,
junior faculty have entirely
the wrong set of incentives.
- So it's been a long time since I've been
a junior faculty member,
but I don't recall it
being any different in terms
of the kind of mentoring I did.
There was a sense in which junior faculty
sometimes can't be a dissertation advisor,
maybe they can be a co-advisor
in some departments,
but they can't be the
advisor, just because of
some of the rules we have, and sometimes
because graduate students
feel closer to people
who are closer to their age and develop
relationships with them, they sometimes
lean on junior faculty in ways as if
they're advisors and then that
junior faculty member doesn't get credit
for being the advisor,
because isn't the advisor,
so I've heard that from
junior faculty members here.
So I think to be careful of,
to acknowledge that untenured professors
need to protect their research time
and might not be getting credit for being
dissertation advisors, even though they're
offering a kind of mentorship,
so I think that's
something to be aware of,
but I think that actual mentoring,
the kinds of mentoring we do,
I don't think it's all that different
before you have tenure
and after you have tenure.
- Thank you, I wanna throw
in a sort of follow up,
which is one of the topics that we had,
and it's around sort of
building your own mentorship
as faculty members and how
that's changed over your careers,
'cause I think that's somewhat
related to this question,
or I'm imagining that this
question is partially about
students becoming faculty
members and then both
mentoring graduate students of their own,
but I think it's
important to remember that
mentorship does not exist
in graduate school alone,
and that this is something
that will continue to happen.
So does anyone wanna speak to
sort of how you've continued
to cultivate these sorts of relationships
with colleagues and friends and others?
- Yeah, sure, so I'm still in touch
with my own dissertation advisor
lo these many decades later,
and so some of these relationships are
lifelong relationships
and that's a good thing.
And I'm still in touch
with many of my own former
graduate students, again,
lifelong relationships
in the best scenario.
And that's something that
becomes, as Kelly said before,
more personal over time
is something that might
start out as a professional relationship,
becomes more of a friendship and more
of a peer relationship,
and that's good to know.
And I think that all of us will always be
in need of advice and honest, constructive
feedback from people, and so the kinds of
work that one does as a mentor or a mentee
is something that you're always gonna
want that with other people.
So it's not necessarily
mentoring once you're
later in life, you don't
necessarily call it mentoring,
but in some ways it's similar.
- Yeah, I can certainly echo that.
I've kept in touch with a
lot of my former students,
in fact, just this semester,
I had a couple of students who graduated
more than 30 years ago,
get in touch with me
for advice about career moves that they
were contemplating, and
that's fairly common,
that they'll reach out to
ask about this or that.
So I think that's a good thing.
In fact, lifelong connections are good.
I still keep in touch
with my own PhD advisor
who's been retired for many years,
but I still talk to him and get insight
from him occasionally, so yeah,
that's definitely important
to maintain connections.
- One thing I'd add is
actually we were talking about
junior professors, one
piece of advice I have
is after graduating from PhD
and getting your first job,
especially if that's at
an academics institution,
it's actually very important
as a junior professor
to get mentors, and right now I think
I mentor several junior faculty.
So our business school
recently set up a more formal
mentorship program between
senior and junior faculty,
that started only two years ago,
and before we didn't
have the system set up,
so in a place where this
system isn't set up,
it's really important to go
out and find your own people.
In a PhD program, usually
mentors are assigned to you,
you're in a lab, it's just the
structure is already there,
whereas once you start your first job,
that's when I think it's really on
the new professors to go out
and find their own network.
- I'm gonna skip around a little bit,
because I'm gonna try and
keep these topically related.
But so we got a question that's sort of
related to what you were
just speaking to Kelly,
which is about actually forming
a dissertation committee,
but how to approach professors
or find the right match,
but also following the comment
on tenure versus tenure
track, should we try to have
more senior faculty on our committee?
Would you recommend sort of diversifying
the committee so that you're
getting different voices,
or I'm reading into
this a little bit more,
but does anyone wanna speak to that?
- I didn't mean to imply
that junior faculty
are not amazing advisors,
I was just commenting
on the institutional
design, which is often
they don't have incentives to do this,
although they do it anyway.
In terms of forming a
dissertation committee,
I think it really depends
on the specific people
that you're considering.
I think many junior faculty tend to be
a little bit more detail oriented.
So it actually helps to have
some of the younger people
on your committee so they can look through
kind of specific things that you're doing
in your dissertation, your
exact research methods,
whereas older people might be better
at framing or thinking
about the big picture.
Now, there are many exceptions
to this generalization,
but that could be why it's useful to have
all sorts of people on your committee.
- I think it's probably most important
to find the people who you
need and want to work with.
And often that is a mix
of junior and senior.
Given Yale's roles I think
you probably need to have
at least one senior person
on a dissertation committee,
but I think the most
important thing is finding
who's gonna help you
accomplish what you wanna do.
And you figure that out as
you're doing your coursework,
sometimes you come to graduate
school kind of knowing
this is the person I wanna work with,
and sometimes that is
the person you work with
and sometimes it's not, but
as you do your coursework,
as you study for your comprehensive exams,
as you enter into
writing the dissertation,
you figure out who are your people,
and those are the people you ask,
and I don't think it necessarily matters
so much about junior and
senior, it matters that
they're the people who are
gonna be able to advise you.
- Yeah, I can also say,
I don't think it matters
so much about junior and
senior, but there are two things
that I tell students when they're
trying to decide on their committee.
One is, those are the people
who will know you best
when you're graduating,
and they're the ones
who write letters of
recommendation for you,
so you need to think about
what they might be able to,
how they might be able to help you
and advise you in your career path,
but the other thing is you want people
who know the area well enough
to be able to give advice,
and so if you wanna say, well,
I want the most famous
person on my committee,
because they'll be able to
write the strongest letter,
but if they don't know
the field very well,
they're not a good committee member,
so we have a discussion
when a committee is being considered
and who would you like,
and I would give back
pros and cons, and so we finally
resolve and come up with a plan for
who would be the best committee members.
- So there's a question
about how to handle
difficult situations with mentees,
such as social discord
with other students,
productivity issues, do
you sometimes need to be
the bad guy or the bad
person in a situation?
And I think I would tie this back to also
a topic that came up earlier, which is
the honesty of feedback.
And so do you all have sort of...
I would be open to talking about it as
needing to do this work
in the best way possible,
but also if there are difficult
situations that are more,
take more care to work through?
- So yeah, there are a range of situations
and I think it's different
for different students
and the way I see it that
as I get to know
somebody, I get a sense of
how much I can push on them in a sense,
that some people are
really open to being pushed
and want me to push them, and some people
are maybe more sensitive to being pushed,
and I take more care with my honest,
I'm honest with them
all and I push them all,
but some people I can be
a little more blunt with
than with others, and I
think that's a matter of
the same when in friendships
and with real relatives,
you figure out different people
have different personalities
and you try to learn to work with them
to be supportive of them in
a way that'll work for them.
And so it's not always the same,
but there are difficult conversations
and sometimes you have to
have difficult conversations
and you have to, it's
not necessarily pleasant,
but you might need to be involved
in a difficult conversation,
and that's okay.
- I guess my thought on this is that
the best way to handle this is to avoid it
in the first place, so
foster good relationships
from the very start, and I
think that can oftentimes
build the sense of
teamwork and collaboration
that will make it less
likely that that will happen,
but I think as Joanne said, sometimes
situations come up and
best way to approach that
is just to be honest and face up,
not to let it fester and get worse.
- For some of my students who have had,
the issues can range a full spectrum,
but what has been helpful
in the past is actually
I've suggested a leave of absence,
and that's been helpful
just to take a break
from the university environment.
It's actually viewed perhaps better
to have a leave of absence when
you're searching for a job.
It's kind of assumed that
it was for personal reasons
rather than to have
stayed in a PhD program
for a very long time
without a leave of absence
as you're sorting through the same issues,
so I found that could be quite helpful.
Other than that, I don't view it as my job
to be a parent or to dress down a student,
so if some student is
really just not working,
working harder or having some kind of
misbehavior issues, I mean,
there's going to be a limit,
I might comment on it
once, but I'm not going to
further dress down a student.
I don't view that as my job.
- Thank you for that.
So there's a question about how could we
systematically reward good
mentorship at this institution?
So we started talking
about this a little bit,
Kelly was sort of mentioning this,
so how could we do it?
And I would also say, what
is rewarding about it?
As three people who have
received this award,
there must be some incentive
for you personally.
- Well, I can say the
biggest measure of success
I have is how successful the students
that have worked with me go
on after they've graduated,
and I think that's your legacy,
so that's where I would see my reward,
is the success of the
students that worked with me.
- Yeah, I agree, it's not really about
direct rewards from the university,
it's very fun and interesting
to talk to students
about their research ideas and
to guide that process along,
and I like to see how
their projects develop
and where their careers lead,
so that's the reward.
- Yeah, I mean, I agree with what
both Gary and Kelly said,
and I would also say
that I learn a lot from
my graduate students.
They work on projects that
it's not this lab project
where we're all working on the same thing,
they work independently
on their own projects,
and I've learned so much
from reading their work,
and I get to help shape a work
and I don't have to do all the research.
So I love sort of reading
their work and helping
their work along and I learn from that.
And that's part of the reward for me,
the relationships, the
lifelong relationships,
that's important to me,
that's a reward for sure.
And then there is the award
that we all three got,
that was nice too, so there are ways
that this is rewarding, for sure.
- So we sort of answered
parts of a question
that just came in, but
there's a separate piece
that builds on what we
were just talking about,
which is how could we facilitate
improving mentorship skills?
So I guess my pre-question to that is
what do you think the key skills
to being a good mentor are?
And then how would you
encourage graduate students
to build those skills or faculty members
to build those skills?
- One of the things I
encourage graduate students
and postdocs who've working with me
is to mentor undergraduates and actually
have an experience in
mentorship while they're here
and we can work as a team to
learn how to do that
effectively and gain experience.
I think once you go off to
become a faculty member,
it's not cold, you just
have to start learning
how to be a mentor at
that point, you can build
your knowledge as you're
going through school.
- I guess I would say, I would add to that
to be open to these
kinds of relationships,
to listen, to listen is really important,
to be honest,
to be welcoming.
Those seem to me things that are important
just sort of in general
and kind of in life,
but I think they work in
mentoring relationships.
- I never got any training
in how to be a mentor,
it wasn't part of the job search process,
or part of the PhD program, and I imagine
most of my colleagues
also didn't get training
in how to be a mentor,
so here's where I think
having talking to multiple faculty members
can help, we're all
imperfect and we don't have
formal training, so it's
useful for students,
I think, then to piece
together what they need
across multiple different faculty members.
- So we're coming on
time and I know we have
a hard stop at one, but
I wanted to offer you all
the chance to give any
last pieces of advice
as graduate students are
thinking through their own
mentorship philosophies or other things
that you wanted to say
during this conversation
that we just haven't
been able to touch on.
- Well, I guess I would say that
you are great observers and
you can observe your own
professors now and your own
mentors and advisors now,
and that'll help you see what
kind of mentor you wanna be.
You will see, you will have people who
have completely different
personalities than you do,
and maybe their mentoring style
wouldn't be your mentoring style,
but you will find people who
are role models of sorts,
I hope, and you'll be able
to pick up things from them
and learn how how you
might pay it forward.
I know I learned a lot from
my own dissertation advisor,
I just celebrated her
retirement last month
out in California, and I know
I learned a lot from her,
but she's a different personality,
and I had to figure out what
is my own style of mentoring,
and I did that partly by
observing other people
and partly by knowing myself
and knowing what works for me.
- Yeah, I can say that, I
mean, I agree with that,
that you learn by observing, in my case,
when I started out there, there
were no mentoring programs,
we never had any formal mentorship,
I don't think that was even
talked about in those days,
so that's now that's been put in place,
which is a great thing, but
that's not all there is,
you can reach out to people
who can provide advice,
there's both formal
and informal mentoring,
and in fact, informal
mentoring might even be
in many cases the most
useful for career directions
if you find somebody who has a career path
or ideas that help best fit with yours,
reach out and those kinds of
informal mentoring can be really useful.
- I'd just like to echo
something that I think
Joanne said about checking
in often with your mentors.
I think this can be very useful,
especially because
students in the beginning
are concerned I think about
making a good impression,
and that leads to stress
that actually leads them
to just not meet up with us at all,
until they have made significant progress
on their dissertation.
And I think that's unfortunate,
because that can lead
to a lot of wasted effort
in various directions,
and actually by checking
in with us frequently,
that actually allows us
to update our beliefs,
so one meeting in which you
didn't have your work done
is absolutely fine, as
long as you check with us
regularly in future months
and throughout the year
and we can see the
progress of the project.
- Great, well, I wanna thank you all
for your incredibly wise
and judicious advice today
and just for being so gracious
with your time and insights.
And I also want to thank
everyone who participated
in the conversation with the
questions through the chat.
I should say that we do intend to post
the recording of the
conversation on YouTube,
so we'll get that link out to folks soon.
And yes, thank you all for being here,
we really appreciate
it, and we look forward
to seeing you again soon.